shall s it's better to meeting you here
in New York and you are a new yorker and
he tells a little bit about the new york
you grow up in yoga grew up here well
was a fifty years ago it was a kind of
odd mix between Brooklyn and greenwich
village my dad on the bookshop in
Greenwich Village on the corner of
Google Street and a street and it was a
crossroad literary crossroad so I grew
up amidst all of that beat poets were
there all the time and allen ginsberg
was there all the time and all of those
characters and then down the block the
folk revival was going on so Bob Dylan
was there and say ended up running a
little Bob Dylan many years later so
that was one part of my growing up in
New York the other part was Brooklyn and
Brooklyn was rather different there
weren't it wasn't quite so literary but
it was a lot of fun and it was it was
very much amigo boyhood you wrote a book
on Bob Dylan Bob Dylan in America do you
think that somebody like Bob Dylan would
agree with Walt Whitman that without
culture we found a literary spirits
democracy cannot survive I don't think
put it quite that way but it certainly
America couldn't survive without it and
Bob Dylan's work it's very much a
contemplation and absorption of many
different layers of American culture
musical first and foremost but literary
as well and he retransfer he transforms
those into his art but it's always
drawing on the deep deep currents
subterranean in some cases sometimes not
so but that is his art or rather that's
those the materials for his art he's a
kind of magician or alchemist and he
turns it into something very
new but he is quintessentially American
and I think that he sees the spirit of
America very much in its culture and
Saul and his poetry sure so he would
agree i mean-- democracy was a big word
for women because it was a big word in
the 19th century I mean America was the
very first blasting Republic of its kind
and democracy was the way that we look
to the future in America democracy was a
very big word the word has changed by
the time we get to the night into into
the twentieth and into the 21st century
so it wouldn't have quite the same
residence for someone like while doing
as it did for for Whitman but the idea
is pretty much the same yeah it's a New
Yorker and you also know a quite
Parliament like Philip Roth the great
novelist who wrote this remarkable book
the plot against America yeah and it's a
kind of sequel to Sinclair Lewis it
can't happen here to almost prophetic
novels on well fascism can come to
America as well and what makes you that
optimistic that it can't happen here
well I mean look America has been very
lucky so far I mean we always the times
of great crisis we come over the Lincoln
or FDR I'm hoping that we'll find
someone like that now I'm optimistic
because what Philip Roth in that novel
very brilliantly captures as elements of
a fascist America that are very much
there and very much around I don't see
them as having the kind of power that
they've had in Europe for example I
don't see it happening today I think
that it'll be before even you can get
men a measure of power that it would be
I do believe that's the case that's not
to say that it isn't there that's not to
say that it's not dangerous and it's
certainly not to say that we one
shouldn't fight it with all one's might
but I wouldn't go in with the kind of uh
or about you know America is about to
fall the brilliance of that novel in
fact you see at the end everything kind
of turns out alright I think things
things turn out okay in the end and
that's not just wishful thinking there's
something about the dynamic of what's
going on even in that novel where things
are going to work out all right um part
of its just you know a matter of
temperament I mean I'm i prefer the
happy warrior to the you know to the
gloomy veteran I don't say the system is
broken I see the system is having been
moved and taking very far in a crazy
direction by one political party and
that has to be set right again I think
it will be set right again but I don't
think institutionally we're in a crisis
I think rather one party has gotten so
extreme that it is seized upon what it
can within the system to try and clog
the system up that's there that's there
that your purport that's what they want
to do they want it to be dysfunctional
that's rare it's happened before but I
don't think that it means the system is
so long there's nothing wrong that one
election cannot do